I wasn't going to tell this story but um
so you know what this is like I got a
job and I couldn't do it because I had
to do I was contractually obligated to
do another job and I was really sad cuz
I wanted this job so bad and I was
walking around a flea market in La just
like oh my God what's going to happen is
everything going to be okay I was so
nervous and this young girl ran up to me
and she goes can I just stop you for one
second and I'm like okay and she goes
I'm a psychic and I'm like okay and she
goes my grandmother's a psychic my mom's
a psychic and I'm just I need to tell
you something you just got blocked from
doing something and it's going to be
okay but you're not on the path you
should be you're supposed to be like
you're supposed to be like a Drew
Barrymore
what no and it meant the world to me and
it was like such a sign I was like
everything's going to be okay I just
have to hang in there and everything's
going to be okay cuz I'm going to be
like a Drew Barry more oh my God if I
could only be half
away are you kidding isn't that the best
well you know what I think for me you
put out so many films that I return to
over and over and over and they're like
medicine you know and you're like major
award-winning thespian you do dramas you
do musicals you're you do theater you do
Shakespeare in the park you do
everything but you are also synonymous
with a lot of Joyful films and I you
know I wonder if that has any event
diagram with us because I did not do the
serious Awards like thing I I I always I
stayed more on the the lighter side you
know of things I I think they're
actually incredibly important and I
think it's really important like Eileen
for example that's a movie that sort of
makes you doubt reality okay by the way
it's so good thank you very much
thinking about it okay so it's like out
of another era I feel like they the 40s
the 50s the 60s there's a very sexy tone
also and I'm in Total Rapture oh God
thank with you and when you walk out the
minute you walk out of that car with
those long legs and that like hair I'm
like well yeah I want to go follow her
now why do you think that ien needs
someone like you so badly in life
because her life's not fair her life's
just not fair it's uh Massachusetts
1964 she's a young woman who hasn't
really distinguished herself but she's
also grew up in an unbelievably
difficult situation her father is a cop
and her home life was really really
really troubled he her father is an
alcoholic her mom died of cancer I know
this sounds really sad uh because it is
she's sad and she's trapped and she's 24
years old working in a boy's prison and
this looks like it's going to be her
life and she doesn't have any love and
she doesn't have any tenderness and in
walks this sort of really modern woman
who has different ideas about the way
things could be and she Sparks an idea
of Eileen about how she might be um it's
really just an extraordinary tone of a
film that I feel like we are deprived of
honestly these character studies uh
these lives that you get to peek inside
of and when you walk into her life
there's no wonder you want to go on that
magic carpet you know with her you
follow her anywhere
[Music]
yeah